[Musique]
le 17 février dernier l'ancien ministre
et actuel maire de draveil a été
condamné à cinq ans de prison dont trois
ferme pour viol agressions sexuelles en
réunion
il est d'ailleurs actuellement en prison
il est écroué à l'issue même de
l'audience
il refuse de démissionner il considère
qu'il peut tout à fait eu il est empêché
selon lui et qui peut continuer
d'exercer son mandat et il jouait à
monte grâce à un pourvoi en cassation
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le premier
ministre que viols et agressions
sexuelles en réunion pourrait tout est
fait à qualifier de fait privant les
luttes de temps et et morales
nécessaires pour ses fonctions vous avez
le pouvoir je réponds collègues vous
avez le pouvoir en conseil des ministres
de démettre ce mr qu'attendez vous pour
le faire
c'est la loi décidément les oppositions
en demande beaucoup à l'exécutif les
oppositions demande à l'exécutif
d'intervenir dans le cadre de décisions
juridictionnelles qui je le redis ne dit
pas non c'est oui qui je le redis
dépendent exclusivement exclusivement
des magistrats notre pays qui sont
indépendants quand on dirige les
magistrats et que l'on est membre de
l'exécutif
alors on n'est plus dans une démocratie
quant au reste madame la sénatrice vous
qui est respectueuse je le suppose de la
présomption d'innocence présomption
d'innocence mis en avant par madame
elisabeth guigou dans une loi
merveilleuse que vous connaissez
forcément il me semble que ce
justiciable a formé un pourvoi en
cassation que la décision dès lors n'est
pas définitive et qu'il se débrouille
avec sa conscience ou demandé à
l'exécutif d'intervenir là dedans mais
franchement quelle hérésie
or ce que je demande avait déjà été fait
à plusieurs reprises deuxièmement je
n'aurais jamais cru que le gouvernement
envoie pour répondre à ma question
l'avocat de georges tron celui qui a
traité de menteuse
les victimes pendant tout le procès et
qui continue aujourd'hui les traiter de
menteuse en arguant de la présomption
d'innocence alors que vous avez été
condamné
la parole joe rappelle quand on ne prend
pas la question pour d'effets personnels
je le rappelle à l'ensemble des chaînes
a peur c'est un principe qu'il convient
de respecter
[Applaudissements]
c'est le garde des sceaux c'est moi qui
préside
[Musique]
quel choix allez vous effectuer pour
ouvrir en urgence dans les jours à venir
des lits de réanimation et allez vous
prendre des dispositions pour sortir les
vaccins de la logique du marché
en levant les brevets et pour accélérer
considérablement la réalisation et la
production d'un vaccin français quels
enseignements tirer en août cette crise
n'aurait pu attendre la fin de la crise
pour le faire on n'a pas fait ça
s'appelle le ségur de la santé ça
s'appelle le 7 9
y a rien dedans 9 milliards et demi
d'euros comment pouvez-vous dire y'a
rien dedans je viens d'annoncer 19
milliards pour le volet investissement
madame la présidente et c'est
extrêmement important moi qui ai connu
les gens s'y fier les plan hôpital 2007
et hôpital 2012
c'est 50% de plus que ces deux plans
réuni que vous allez que nous allons que
la nation engagée au bénéfice du service
santé
[Musique]